ja alles gut kommt dann kann das besser
sagt man du musst angreifen wird auf dem
boden teil hat er auch eine robin gibb
ihn kommt ja auch mit eltern es schneit
das service kids und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video heute spielen wir
auf 300 sg und der martin schmitt dabei
denn ich bin bei meiner familie und das
ist ja quasi schon tradition dass ich
immer wieder ins wasser falle immer
wieder ich bei meiner familie bin hier
diese challenge fahrt aufnehme nämlich
die abwechselnd challenge ich kenne auch
nicht irgendwo hin die sich dadurch
auszeichnet dass maxi nicht immer
unterschiedliche steuerung haben und
wieder ein bisschen or agent
er wird als anderen spielen müssen wir
machen das heute so sobald einer von uns
ein gegner tötet müsste muss er
innerhalb von zehn sekunden die
steuerung an den anderen übergeben
zehn sekunden hatten stoiber damals
gesagt bzw innerhalb von zehn sekunden
den pc verlassen also die steuern schon
aus den händen geben was der andere
macht ist seine sache
wir müssen also versuchen hier irgendwie
ne ordentliche runde hin zu klatschen ja
wir hatten gerade eben schon pageplace
so und ich habe auch tatsächlich
bisschen zeit leute weil ich jetzt
gleich weiter muss nach köln
zurückkehren weil ich morgen von köln
aus nach berlin pflege zu star wars
premiere pipapo opposition die kiste
zwölf sekunden später lasse mir dieses
thema einfach mal quasi um eine kiste
ist drauf selbst geschädigt wenn ich
auch ich bin auch infiziert mit der fis
sprache die sprache ja aber noch nicht
von luzie verziert und ich werde auch
versuchen mein köln wenn das lud mich
ein panisches infiziert mit seinen
wollen wir gar nicht debattiert mit
allen möglichen geschlechtskrankheiten
aber sie haben nichts mit mir zu tun am
puls zu leisten ja gut dann kann ich
immer eine leggins bekommt in dem alter
minecraft kisten kann man öffnen kann
als witzig ist jung was das für amish
equipment man vergessen euch auch
öffentlich nichts drin wie viele kisten
soll dieser junge mann noch öffnen bis
er ordentliches equipment erhält die
ganze ist es etwas erschwert und ich
mache zwar billig findet man leute
wissen 0 gegner aber ich kann doch noch
gucken ob da wird hier unten aus dem
stern equipment okay jetzt habe ich acht
teile der mauer krankheit fast so
schnell wie dsl stein deshalb gleich
ziemlich steinig aus
das frage ich mich wie die leute landen
immer in den drittliga sie jetzt mit
schön mit dir leute schütteln sich der
service erweitert alter hoffentlich und
community leben der hat alter schwede
pass auf pass auf dass du nicht stürzt
du mir bitte stellt sich okay ich habe
allerdings andere stellen also es kann
sein ist einfach den abgrund du kannst
ihr braucht kann sich auch direkt kurz
ende aber ist erst mal was trägst du
okay kommt da ja hast ein apfel
du kannst die beiden gold ab verkraften
der junge aber kann man auch finden
ich weiß nicht wie es mittlerweile es
mit dem equipment aber auf jeden fall da
war es um so das kann sich jetzt
ziemlich sehen lassen würde ich sagen
in der farb- das nicht dauerhaft auch
wort perfekt
sie guckt das soll ich gerade eben
zeigen dass wir noch keinen schnaps oder
gar nicht reden
das ist ein hacker ist ja aber du hast
nie wort gesagt dass es noch zum archiv
vor meinem inneren auge hatte ich schon
die die einblendung von musik
der bbi soll jetzt nichts mädchen müssen
das ist das ergebnis eine entsprechende
karte okay anders als relativ kleine
gehen damit allerdings das ist ganz
machbar aus eigentlich das paar teile ja
schön mit der hotline
ja ja das sieht gut aus er hatte gold
apfel sonst eigentlich ziemlich schlecht
ziemlich stark betroffen na okay gut
versucht komm ich habt ihr denn da kann
ich übernehmen und dann macht mir das
ding schönen das match ist uns wird es
richtig dick sind die anderen beiden
alte der summer in chanti der typ der
andere ja aber es leben noch vier also
der sollte sich die genannten
beschäftigen kaum noch als person einer
dachte ich natürlich natürlich auch
arcandor helfen es geht hier nicht weil
deshalb sind capital hat 12 übernehme
ich übernehme ich übernehmen wenn heißt
dass wir nur leisten hatte tnt hier
vorne
das ganze bestimmt dabei tnt das nenne
ich mal die golden girl oder das nicht
mehr so mit
ich habe mir meine jetzt ist mal wieder
die sache wie machen zudem fms ich packe
es mal auf f2 spieler leute wie sie
jetzt gegen diese andere equipment
rapper dann wird man wieder frei lampe
wir können theoretisch in die mitte ach
scheiße meiner hotkey funktionieren auch
nicht okay dann muss ich dringend es ja
müsste ich wollte mehr verkraften
das wird nur nicht funktionieren
walter weil er hier was dagegen hat aber
hat er news infos entstand ich weiß noch
ein schwert ich will kurz hoffen doch
das geht ja alles gut wir es einfach
diesen fall hat eingeschlossen
und 25 und noch ein stück nach einer
wand dieses segment ist hart umkämpft
ja weil staatliche hilfen verhandelt der
junge
ich bin jetzt aber ich sag es ist es
wird gehen eigentlich was alles gute
sondern darum kommen ja halb halb so
wild kannst schnell recht haben drei
tage später mal gucken mal anfängt zu
schreiben softproject jetzt bin ich voll
korrekt okay leute vorbereitet 90
sekunden alter alle enchanted island
erst wahrscheinlich ein staat muss drauf
weiß man nicht leute können auch
einschalten alle fühlen sich ja ich hab
den abschied hätte die taste nicht
gefunden ist okay wir anfangs ein
powerplay auf meinen vater kurz
ja alles gut kommt ein camp das besser
sagt man du musst angreifen wird auf den
boden alle hat er auch einen komplex ja
auch mit agnes klein und der wird noch
richtig gelesen habe hat er mich für ihn
sagte junge-reyer
wir haben's geschafft alter alt
abgepackt dafür gibt's den gp von uns
intensiv verstehen dass der held und
können so das war es von uns leute für
mich geht es direkt weiter nach köln
das war von mir das was von hier haut
rein selbe zeit selber stelle selbe
welle liegt nun die schnelle pick mit
quelle und der wand led ja theorie